au moment où je vous parle mesdames et
messieurs les députés une tragédie
humanitaire effroyable frappe la ville
d'alep et sa population civile les
femmes et les enfants d'alep après des
mois de siège suit sous les bombes et
sont les victimes d'innombrables
atrocités selon divers témoignages
les hommes de moins de 40 ans sont
arrêtés
enrôlé de force parfois exécutés par
l'armée syrienne
avec l'appui des forces favorables au
régime de bachar al assad
à commencer par la russie ces atrocités
qui peuvent être constitutifs de crimes
de guerre voire de crimes contre
l'humanité sont accomplies avec un
cynisme et avec une cruauté inouïe c'est
l'honneur de la france d'avoir été l'une
des seules nations a tenté de s'opposer
dès l'été 2013 à la guerre totale menée
par bachar al assad contre son propre
peuple
jamais nous n'accepterons au nom d'un
prétendu réalisme de nous allier
aujourd'hui avec les responsables du
martyr d'alep ce sont les mêmes des
mêmes et ont laissé dahesh reprendre
palmyre et au nom du gouvernement de la
france et j'en suis sûr
en votre nom à tous je dénonce l'horreur
de ces massacres et affirme que ceux qui
les ont perpétrées auront à en rendre
compte devant la communauté
internationale à vous avec vous je sais
qu'ils connaîtront le jugement sévère de
l'histoire